[Music]
I'd say the biggest way that Julie
helped me get into character so to speak
is I could no I mean seriously is that I
could always tell when she thought I was
acting and that because the goal of
these movies is to have as little
artifice in front of the camera as
possible we can't act because if we act
it doesn't work those films have to be
it's not that if we act it doesn't work
if we if we sense we're acting it just
becomes fake what's interesting about
the movies is this kind of non action it
starts to become then a mother's jeweis
is it's all about the emotional arm and
in it being a real authentic one and so
we have to get out of the way and really
let Jesse and Celine present themselves
it's the hardest part of those films and
it's really really really really hard I
mean everything raised by actors you
know I've been an actress since of 14
and nothing is harder than just doing
very very simple things like walking and
talking and pretending that we've been
together for nine years and you know and
that means you're tearing that you're
trying and then I'm attracted to him and
that you know I'm okay with him holding
my hand when I would never let that
happen in real life
[Music]
you know in real life we really don't
like each other
so we really maybe it's the allergy I
mean I would call it allergic would you
I feel allergic to you yeah me too
like a night like you know those cats
with short hair they kind of like what I
feel when I'm seriously the chemistry is
just it's all acting yeah no serious -
because we have no real chemistry in
their life no we do it's not we don't
know we don't hate each other but you
know we don't we're not you know we're
not we're not sexually active with each
other that's good
we do everything we've been all in this
we keep making okay we like it all night
oh maybe we like it
Julian I have an idea we want to do I'm
Lucy and as you know like the life story
anyway okay sorry basically we we lock
ourselves in a room wherever it is
Greece France you know Vienna Paris you
know see now and then we we just work
work work work work until we but what
does work mean what is that's probably
writing and then we write scenes we
bounce off ideas we propose scenes
endings that it just doesn't stop like
we spend 12 hours a day
we have eat a lot of food during that
time because it helps us sing
[Music]
you